ce sera la troisième nomination à la
cour suprême de donald trump une
audition très attendue et miccoli
barrette magistrat de 48 ans fait face
au comité sénatorial présidée par le
sénateur républicain lindsey graham de
succomber est longue comme shenzhen oui
ce sera une longue semaine dit il je ne
demande qu'une chose au comité soyons
respectueux le monde nous regarde
car les démocrates sont furieuses la
nomination d'un juge à la cour suprême
aurait dû se faire après les élections
selon eux en février 2016 lorsque barack
obama avait tenté de nommer un juge à la
cour suprême
les républicains s'étaient farouchement
opposés il affirmait alors que c'était
trop près de la vague verte orale or à
moins d'un mois des élections dans notre
chambre a nommé émus quand ni barrette
avec l'aval du sénat cette fois qu'une
majorité républicaine le président
champion de nous ramener en arrière dit
kamala harris casse est professeur de
droit et la coqueluche des milieux
religieux
elle est contre l'avortement pour une
plus grande flexibilité sur le droit du
port d'armes et plusieurs craignent
qu'elles rendent la loi sur
l'assurance-santé inconstitutionnelle je
crois au pouvoir de la prière dit elle
et c'est encourageant de savoir que tant
de personnes ont prié pour moi si je
suis confirmé
je m'engage à remplir mon devoir de
manière impartiale
nous sommes la génération pro vie dit
elle est contre l'avortement avec mg
icon hibarette la majorité des juges à
la cour suprême seront pro-vie notre
président est un fasciste dit qu'elle
est nous lui permettons de changer nos
vies pour les prochaines 30 40 d'année
avec la nomination des micros ni
barrette à la cour suprême
ils seront six juges conservateurs
contre trois libéraux ici à des
bootleggers keith radio-canada
washington